Check out the Charlie's Angels trailer right now!
I think, women can do anything.
Just because they can, doesn't mean they should.
But I have so many talents.
Who are you?
Aren't just the decoys there?
Outstanding, angels!
You have a new client.
Who is she?
I can't sleep at night.
I am the lead programmer on a product that can revolutionize the power industry,
but there is a possibility it can be weaponized.
Ulema, we need to go.
Are you the waitress?
No, I'm Jane.
Who are you?
I'm Barsley.
Welcome to the sounds of agencies.
We exist because traditional law enforcement can't keep up.
You guys are like lady spies.
Thanks, former MI6.
Oh God, what did you do to spend?
I'm compressed as carotid and deoxygenated his brainstem.
Well, that sounds painful.
Don't worry. He's gonna wake up.
Unless he doesn't...
Sabina runs the ground game.
So annual stuff.
Let's get the weapon, before it becomes every bad guys favorite new toy.
Take her to the closet, cheer her up.
We're gonna need some wigs...
...toys...
Heisty!
...clothes.
Ah! We still in the first posit.
There's another closet.
Oh my god!
Oh! Mints.
Let's just stop the touching. Some of these blow up.
I love fostering.
Jen, are you flirting? With a handsome nerd?
Of course not.
How'd that feel, cuz it looked like it felt really good.
It felt nice.
Good morning, angels!
Good morning, Charlie!